[Music]
[Music]
we had an enormous amount of fun on the
first film
good good excellent
there was an energy on set that it was
the first time you'd ever seen anything
like this
i was excited about everything that it
could be when i saw the dinosaur in the
trailer and i saw the ripples on the
water i was like oh my gosh it really
defined my generation this film
i cried the first time i saw dinosaurs
suddenly that which had never seemed
real before
now was totally real and i realized at
that moment that cinema forever had
changed
jurassic world dominion is the
culmination of the franchise it
concludes a story that stephen spielberg
started telling in 1993 when we were
making jurassic world i knew it was
going to be really special
i could never have imagined we'd be here
working alongside samuel and jeff
goldblum and laura dern it's pretty
fantastic it is so much fun it is
everything we could have ever hoped for
and more i thought it was a fantastic
idea to bring these two worlds together
it's been a great privilege to be a
custodian of something like this our
legacy characters our jurassic world
characters are back
our storylines intersect it's the
convergence of the two franchises
we need to fix a terrible mistake and
most importantly go on a true
honest-to-god scary as hell adventure
this is what everything has been leading
to i could use your expertise you
comment or what
hold on tight
why
do they always have to go bigger
don't move
[Music]
i wanted to show them something that
wasn't an illusion
something that was real
something that we could
see
and touch
creation
is an act of sheer will
life
will find a way
we can't keep her here forever
they find her we're never gonna see her
again we gotta protect her that's our
job
humans and dinosaurs can't coexist
[Music]
we created an ecological disaster
ellie settler
alan grant
you didn't come out all this way just to
catch up now did you
you coming or what
[Music]
we're racing toward the extinction of
our species
we not only lack dominion over nature
[Music]
we're subordinate to it
[Music]
come back i always come back
that's another plane right
not exactly
don't move
bigger why do they always have to go
bigger
[Music]
you